y
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el presidente de
eeuu donald trump pasará a la historia
por diferentes logros o desaciertos
durante su mandato durante su mandato
eso dependiendo de la perspectiva desde
la que se mire como sucede en todos los
casos pero sin lugar a dudas será
recordado por ser el único mandatario
hasta ahora en ese país norteamericano
que es acusado en dos ocasiones por la
cámara de representantes- para ser
sometido a un juicio político no es el
único presidente en la historia de ese
país en llegar a esa instancia hagamos
un repaso por otros casos similares en
1868 el demócrata andrew johnson ve todo
varios proyectos de ley de derechos
civiles y también tenía un gran afán por
reincorporar a los ex confederados de
nuevo a la unión americana eso generó
discrepancias con los son republicanos
en la cámara de representantes que en
respuesta intentaron destituirlo este
presidente fue absuelto por un voto en
el senado en 1998 en el segundo mandato
del demócrata bill clinton un escándalo
sexual
a que la fiscalía lo acusará de once
delitos merecedores de un proceso de
impugnación finalmente fue absuelto en
el 2019 el presidente el republicano y
actual mandatario donald trump junto a
otros funcionarios de su gobierno fueron
acusados de presionar al gobierno de
ucrania para que investigara a joe biden
que en ese entonces era ex
vicepresidente y candidato a la
presidencia y también para que
investigaran a su hijo hunter byte en
por su relación y actividades
empresariales en ese país europeo fue
absuelto por el senado en dos de los
tres cargos que habían su contra ahora
en 2021 donald trump es acusado por
instigar a una insurrección armada
contra el capitolio en eeuu al menos así
lo argumenta la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes nancy pelosi
escuchemos
y más debe irse es un peligro claro y
presente para la nación que todos amamos
los hechos de violencia ocurridos en el
capitolio en washington el pasado 6 de
enero generaron también grietas y
algunos distanciamientos en el propio
partido republicano así lo dejó ver el
representante a la cámara el republicano
jon cat com
a permitir del presidente de los eeuu
insiste este ataque sin consecuencias es
una amenaza directa para el futuro de
esta democracia por esa razón votaré
para impugnar a este presidente y por su
parte el presidente de donald trump fue
señalado de reaccionar tarde de no haber
llamado a la calma y de no tomar las
medidas a tiempo para dispersar a los
manifestantes que se tomaron el
capitolio cuando más temprano ese mismo
6 de enero había reforzado su mensaje de
seguir manifestándose a cualquier costo
algunos dicen que el mandatario
reaccionó como debía hacerlo otros dicen
que olímpicamente se lavó las manos
escuchemos
quiero ser claro
donde no inequívocamente la violencia
que vimos la semana pasada files la
violencia y el vandalismo no tienen
lugar en nuestro país ni en nuestro
movimiento en ambos bandos ya seas de
derecha o de izquierda
demócrata o republicano republicano
eres negro no hay una justificación para
la violencia sin excusas sin excepciones
para analizar y conocer más detalles
sobre este tema saludamos a michael
schifter el ex presidente del diálogo
interamericano nos acompaña desde la
ciudad de washington y también está con
nosotros césar grajales él es director
nacional de asuntos públicos para la
iniciativa libre él se une a este debate
desde la ciudad de miami en el estado de
florida también se une a esta
conversación por supuesto ustedes hacen
parte de ella y pueden dejar sus
preguntas y comentarios en las redes
sociales se les recuerdo estamos en
facebook y también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter no se encuentran
como france24 bajo ese
sant y luego la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 pues ya tenemos el tema
tenemos el contexto y tenemos a los
invitados y yo quiero comenzar por
conocer las opiniones sobre este tema de
comienzo entonces con michael schifter
en la ciudad de washington sobre su
opinión general de este tema para que
sea nuestro punto de partida es viable
esta acusación no es viable
va a prosperar es un último ataque de
los demócratas simplemente para afectar
este este cierre de gobierno del
presidente trump y por el lado del
presidente de trump hacer una transición
aunque él ya dijo que iba a ser pacífica
y eficaz
simplemente hacerla un poco distinta y
entorpecerle un poco el inicio yo bardem
bueno muchas gracias yo creo que es
importante usted ha dado el contexto muy
bien pero también es importante agregar
me permite que esto tiene historia
pronto está terminando cuatro años como
presidente de eeuu y toda su conducta de
su retórica ha sido en torno de incitar
violencia no es la primera vez es ese es
el caso más dramático grave y peligroso
triste oscuro sí pero él es así un
patrón de su conducta desde que asumió
la presidencia
y hay muchos ejemplos de esto entonces
yo creo que fue muy importante para
mandar un mensaje muy claro y muy
contundente por parte del congreso
de rechazar y decir que esto es
totalmente inaceptable como un
precedente en citar una intervención en
el capitolio el corazón de democracia en
el mundo en eeuu y un símbolo global de
la democracia
entonces yo creo que fue estuvo muy bien
que pasó dos veces es histórico es el
único precedente que ha sido destruido
dos veces ahora pasa al senado y creo
que creo que esto es algo que están
evaluando pero me parece importante que
prospere en el senado la convicción de
que el juicio va al senado y me parece
que que prospera ahí porque si no hay es
difícil pensar y el otro conducta si si
no este que puede hacer un presidente
declarar para justificar el juicio
político claro
césar grajales en la ciudad de miami es
viable para usted esta acusación que ya
pasó y fue aprobada en la cámara de
representantes- cuál es su opinión
bueno varias cosas yo creo que
en alguna parte estoy de acuerdo con
michael en otra un poquito más de
distancia porque yo creo que la parte de
lo que vimos como resultado digamos
final la semana pasada mi opinión es
algo que se ha venido acumulando y es
una adicción que ha venido sucediendo
desde el comienzo de administración de
trump pero no específicamente por el
presidente pero yo creo que también el
otro lado al seguir animando el tema de
que no es mi presidente no gana las
elecciones de manera correcta y eso
dentro del partido de hecho amo dentro
del trómpiz no digamos así genera esas
pasiones y unas pasiones que se van
calentando y que llegamos a ver hasta la
semana pasada donde por supuesto el
presidente en gran parte el tema y la
retórica de que las elecciones fueron
amañadas y que en realidad no fueron un
resultado correcto ese grupo de gente
que ya viene con su cabeza caliente que
ya vienen molestos desde el comienzo del
2016 2017 ya el comienzo de la toma de
decisión de posición del presidente
aunque recordemos
la violencia de hecho en las calles de
washington esa vez que tomó posición de
presidente con quema de carros gente
arrestada en fin un montón de rollos
también todo eso se va acumulando y se
junta con otro grupo de gente que tiene
también este está digamos estas
preocupaciones que el que si al
traumatismo que se alimenta también de
lo que el presidente está diciendo y
vemos lo que vimos la semana pasada
ahora ayer sucede
en la votación en la cámara para la
destitución del presidente esto
obviamente ya hemos escuchado el
presidente del senado actual porque la
próxima semana ya no va a ser el
presidente del senado mitch mcconnell
que ha dicho que él posiblemente ha
hablado con algunas personas votaría en
favor de aprobar esa destitución del
presidente sin embargo recordemos que es
un escenario particular porque el
presidente a partir de la próxima semana
ya no va a ser presidente y va a ser un
ciudadano más yo considero que eso va a
llevar muchas semanas pero también
recordemos más allá de ser presidente la
semana pasada instó a esta situación y
tiene gran culpa en ello lo que pasó hay
que escuchar su parte hay que huir o
argumentos y yo creo que es ahí donde
tiene que jugar un papel importante para
recordar que el país también tiene algo
importante y es el debido proceso y hay
que escuchar a todas las personas y
todos argumentos incluyendo si tenemos
opiniones encontradas donde creemos y la
persona es culpable o no hay que dejarle
eso a los jueces y en este caso los
jueces los jurados y en este caso los
jurados van a ser los senadores de eeuu
y esa
escuchad el presidente tendrá lugar dado
el caso que el senado vote a favor de
continuar en este proceso de un juicio
político y se ha convocado al presidente
para dar como usted dice es la versión
de los hechos y su perspectiva sobre lo
que sucedió el 6 de enero yo le añadiría
a esa molestia que tienen los ciudadanos
y hace discurso que han estado oyendo a
lo largo de estos cuatro años que
ustedes dos coinciden en ese punto y la
molestia que hay generalizada en eeuu
también por el tema de la pandemia del
cob y 19 por el desempeño de la economía
por la pérdida de trabajos y eso genera
también aún más rabia por parte de los
ciudadanos estadounidenses la gran
pregunta que uno se hace en este momento
y teniendo en cuenta el escenario que
cambia el senado a partir de la próxima
semana es si en esa cámara alta michael
él
tendrá futuro este esta propuesta hacer
un juicio político al presidente de
trump dependiendo esos y de cómo queden
acomodados los escaños en el senado y
como sea el panorama político la otra
todo puede cambiar
sí es cierto es la verdad es que la
administración enfrenta un gran dilema y
yo creo que el mismo presidente electo
bailén es ambivalente sobre este tema
porque el país como usted mencionó muy
bien se encuentra un momento de crisis
profundo sanitaria y económica hay 4000
que están muriendo cada día en este país
por el cover entonces hay urgencia de
hacer legislativas hacer leyes para
responder a esa crisis y también
confirmar los los que han sido nombrados
por el confirmar el gabinete de presente
baile entonces la preocupación es que si
va al un juicio y hay debido su proceso
y hay que respetar todas las leyes y eso
debería eso podría correr el riesgo de
prolongar ese tiempo
y no atender la crisis inmediata
entonces hay que buscar en que el libro
hay unos que dicen que bueno hay que
hacer ambos puede ser ambos pero es no
es fácil eso es un dilema a mi juicio
bastante complicado césar cuál es su
perspectiva tendrá prosperará esto en la
cámara alta en el senado este este
pedido de juicio político
yo creo que michael está acertado en lo
que dice es verdad es no hay tanto
digamos si prospera y termina siendo
condena digamos al presidente de yemen y
se encuentra culpable de los cargos que
se le imputa o se le imputó el día de
ayer en la institución sino esto este
impeachment o esta institución en el
senado beneficia a la nueva
administración en el largo plazo es
verdad lo que lo que menciona marcó las
prioridades ahorita es el tema del hobby
el desempleo
y restituir la confianza sobre todo del
país en las instituciones del país el
país está muy dividido políticamente
tanto republicanos dentro del partido
republicano demócrata el centro del
partido demócratas ambos partidos entre
sí yo creo que ahí es donde el
presidente electo próximamente la semana
que viene presidente bayrén tiene que
decidir si verdaderamente dedicarle
mucho tiempo a eso es beneficioso y
saludable para la democracia de eeuu
para la unificación de nuestra nación y
recuperación
rápidamente del país y eso obviamente
los primeros 100 días de su
administración yo creo que le ocuparía
varias semanas
si esto se decirte le dedicó a toda la
fuerza a este proceso de institución yo
no va a ser una cosa de un día o dos
días no van a hacer una cosa de varias
semanas que compromete esa gente del
presidente más adelante quiero que
analicemos ese escenario para el
presidente electo joe biden y como éste
ustedes han mencionado algunos algunos
puntos importantes sobre cómo este
proceso podría afectar o no el inicio de
su gobierno antes
de eso quiero que hagamos un repaso de
cómo fue la votación en la cámara de
representantes el día de ayer que avaló
estos puntos para acusar al presidente
por esta insurrección el pasado 6 de
enero veamos en la gráfica y ven ustedes
cómo fue la votación en la cámara de
representantes del partido demócrata
votos y 222 votos a favor 0 en contra el
republicano 10 votaron a favor de
iniciar este juicio político 197 votaron
en contra esto es un total de 232 contra
197 votos
césar a que llama la atención son estos
10 votos de representantes republicanos
que votaron a favor del inicio de este
juicio político esto deja en evidencia
algo que ya habíamos hablado varias
veces los medios de comunicación y que
se notas en washington y es esas grietas
esas pequeñas fisuras que se están dando
al interior del partido republicano que
tan fisurado está el partido republicano
que tanto se puede desprender de trump
una vez él termine su mandato
césar
yo creo que es la yo creo que la parte
digamos importante y clave para el
partido republicano es poder entender
cuáles son las necesidades o qué es lo
que lleva digamos a varios líderes
dentro de parte político apoyar el
presidente a capa y espada obviamente el
tema de la llamada pasada un tema de
basta para muchos que habían estado con
el presidente durante los cuatro años
también esta es mi opinión personal creo
que algunos de los que votaron son
representantes de distritos que tienen
digamos un riesgo político si han votado
a favor del presidente porque el próximo
año son recordemos elección a través del
congreso y a lo mejor votaron pensando
en eso pero digamos que el
distanciamiento
he tomado algunos vídeos políticos
independientemente de estos diez creo
que es un basta de
de la posición digamos del lenguaje y de
la actitud del presidente en muchos
momentos ahora cómo queda el partido
cómo se puede recuperar pero lo
importante es escuchar las necesidades
que tienen esos 75 millones que votaron
presidentes el presidente al final no
termina siendo convicto en el senado y
podría postularse en esos cuatro años yo
creo que en 24 años que le quedaría el
partido republicano mi opinión es
demostrarle a esos 75 millones de
personas que votaron presidente camps
que puede haber un líder que representa
esas necesidades y esos miedos y las
preocupaciones que ellos tienen pero un
líder que es moderado un líder que tal
vez tiene un lenguaje y una forma de
hablar diferente que no compromete la
agenda política con ataques personales o
cuentas personales que es lo que muchas
personas han encontrado desde antes y
mickael cuál es su opinión es muy
diciente que tres líderes importantes
del partido republicano en la cámara
estoy hablando de jong cat co que lo
mencionábamos acá que también se une a
la representante por wyoming que también
es presidente de la conferencia
republicana de la cámara
sídney así como su compañero de illinois
adam kinzinger han dicho no apoyamos más
al presidente estamos a favor de un
juicio político son es muy diciente que
el partido tiene problemas en el
interior y que trump ha generado
discrepancias
bueno yo creo que mi reacción es por fin
yo creo que es lo que está esperando
mucha gente por 4 años y hasta ahora ha
sido totalmente alineado y recuerde que
en la primera destrucción fue siento los
republicanos respaldaron a trump por por
lo menos 10 toma a gran distancia y no
estaban dispuestos y lo myanmar
llamativo es la skinny que usted
mencionó que viene que la hija del ex
vicepresidente dick cheney que no puede
ser más conservador tienen familia muy
conservador en la historia de eeuu y yo
creo que esto es él y sus palabras
fueron durísimos fueron durísimos contra
trump entonces yo creo que ese marca un
cambio importante que a mi juicio viene
un poco tarde pero es bienvenido hay que
también tomar en cuenta que muchos de
los republicanos que votaron en contra
de la destrucción votaron en contra
por miedo de amenazas a sus familias a
su staff y hay testimonios clarísimo
sobre esto han dicho esto ha comentado a
muchos periodistas entonces hubiera sido
a mi juicio muchos más que votaron en
contra pero tiene mucho miedo miedo por
lo que pueda pasar en su familia pero
también miedo de que el voto o sea en
los votantes es cierto que donald trump
a pesar de todo increíblemente tiene 80
por ciento de apoyo dentro del partido
republicano y en este momento no hay
otro líder hay que reconocer esto pero
yo no tengo duda que muchos más que diez
republicanos estaban totalmente
indignados por lo que pasó el 6 de su
conducto el 6 de enero y tenían una
posición en contra pero votaron alinear
apoyar el presidente y resistir a votar
en contra de la propuesta de estudio lo
volver a la segunda vez michael y sumado
a ese 80% que usted menciona que tiene
presidente de apoyo al interior del
partido lo hemos visto a lo largo de
estos cuatro años y es que el presidente
de trump no es un político el mismo lo
ha dicho y no es un político habitual y
él logra de estas tormentas sacar algo a
favor que podría jugarle a favor al
presidente de trump en este escenario a
pocos días de finalizar su mandato de
entregar el poder a joe biden y también
para cerrar su historia esos cuatro años
de una manera más digna
bueno yo creo que él él tiene razón yo
creo que si uno mira su carrera aún
antes de ser presidente de tus caribe
del negocio
él ha sido jugado el papel de la víctima
y va a hacer todo posible para
aprovechar esto que todo el mundo estaba
contra él desde el principio que fue una
farsa todo destitución y todo y yo creo
que podría yo creo que yo creo que hay
gente que lo va a seguir lo va a creer
esto esto tenemos que tenemos que
aceptar entonces hay un riesgo también
para los demócratas que se pasan un poco
porque esto puede fortalecer la posición
política del presidente de trump tiene
seis jugadores y tiene va a presentarse
en 2024 yo no descarto que es candidato
serio depende de lo que pase en el
senado obviamente
y yo creo que el el eres muy hábil ha
sido un exitoso de aprovechar los
excesos de sus enemigos entonces yo creo
que los boquetes tienen que manejar eso
con bastante cuidado para no producir el
efecto contrario lo que está buscando se
ser tomando como un punto de partida a
un supuesto voto a favor por parte del
senado la cámara alta para realizar este
juicio político supongamos que hay una
acusación formal supongamos que entonces
el presidente ya ex presidente para esa
instancia porque la cámara dijo que se
reunirá a partir del 19 de enero o sea
la próxima semana un día antes del
presidente de trump entregar la silla
presidencial en la casa blanca cuáles
pueden ser los escenarios que tenga el
presidente en esa instancia en términos
de acusaciones o de ser absuelto como
puede ser ese posible escenario estos
barajando un poco hacia adelante hacia
el frente
bueno el presidente es absuelto al final
del día yo supongo que en cuatro años
intentará correr nuevamente
como lo mencionaba michael presidente
camps sigue siendo una figura que mueve
masas
independientemente de si estás de
acuerdo o no con su actitud o su forma
de hablar o su retórica si el presidente
es encontrado culpable y verdaderamente
los cargos prosperan en el senado
obviamente ya la carrera política no
tiene ninguna yo creo que las de las
cosas que me imagino han de preocuparle
precisamente trump a partir de la
próxima semana
recordemos que a partir de la próxima
semana más allá del impeachment eres un
ciudadano más y antes de ser presidente
era un empresario y después de ser
presidente seguirá siendo un empresario
y ya enfrenta diferentes crisis
económicas dentro de sus empresas
esta semana se hablaba de quitar el
apoyo a varios de sus campos de golf por
compañías como ahora por estos grupos
como el que es de lo de lo del golf pues
todas esas cosas le afectan también a su
marca a sus hoteles a todo eso y menos
que eso es algo que va a salir a ver
cómo lidiar con ese tema también tiene
una acusación del new york si no me
equivoco con el tema de impuestos
entonces yo creo que todo eso es algo
que
independientemente de cómo falle el
senado en el proceso de la institución
sean 12 semanas de semanas un mes si
esto sigue avanzando y yo creo que son
las prioridades para el al sodio gracias
a hablar si es encontrada reiteró y no
siente al final del proceso de
destitución
supongo que intentará correr dentro de
cuatro años nuevamente la presidencia
pero reitero yo creo que aquí lo más
importante es poder evaluar cuáles
fueron las cosas positivas en la
política en la agenda del presidente
hecho durante los últimos cuatro años yo
particularmente encuentro algunas veces
muy positivas y el partido republicano
reevaluar los líderes que tiene y
unificar el país yo creo que esta
administración tiene que aprovechar este
momento y demostrar que verdaderamente
quiere unir al país
y evitar más división también en caso de
ser condenado el presidente perdería una
pensión vitalicia de 220 mil dólares
anuales y también el derecho a tener en
funerales con honores y ser enterrado en
el cementerio de arlington muy cerca a
la ciudad de washington como ve usted el
panorama michael allí en la ciudad de
washington en ese escenario supuesto de
llegar al senado será apoyado para un
para tener un juicio político y ser
condenado
si yo yo yo tengo la impresión que es
una posición correcta que están usando
los demócratas porque si no hay juicio
político sobre esto entonces qué otra
cosa puede ser pero yo no creo que va a
pasar yo dudo que va a pasar yo creo que
los republicanos a pesar de lo que dijo
el michoacano no está con con ese ánimo
y creo que él mismo dice pedir el mismo
presidente baile que sume el próximo
miércoles es un poco ambivalente con
esto porque él está más enfocado con su
propio agenda y se puede y está un poco
preocupado que esto puede distraer y
prolongar todo lo que tiene que hacer
urgentemente dada la gravedad de la
crisis que enfrenta eeuu a troche no
creo que va a pasar yo creo que es
correcto hacerlo por principio parece
totalmente ha cruzado no olvidemos por
favor que no solamente su conducta y su
retórica el intento de negar la voluntad
del pueblo estadounidense una elección
libre y justa y transparente o sea él
perdió y a pesar de perder el intento
este cambiar el resultado y presionar
funcionarios para para hacer todas las
manipulaciones y todo el fraude para que
el ganar eso eso es un golpe a la
democracia es un debido democracia crea
más grave que esto es difícil imaginar
yo quiero aclarar que dentro de este
análisis que estamos haciendo aquí en el
debate france24 este es un escenario
supuesto esto no ha llegado todavía al
senado falta que la cámara de
representantes determine las evidencias
que va a enviar a la cámara alta para
que allí sea debatido estudiado
necesitaría dos tercios del senado para
ser condenado es decir que los
demócratas necesitarían la votación de
la totalidad de los demócratas más 17
republicanos para que esto prospere y
eso es algo que todavía no se ha
definido entonces es simplemente parte
del análisis hago la aclaración porque
es simplemente un escenario supuesto
ustedes ya lo han mencionado a lo largo
de sus intervenciones césar y maicon y
es este momento de la transición este
juicio político cae muy mal en este
momento de transición cuando el
presidente electo joe biden necesita que
le sea aprobado lo más pronto posible un
ambicioso plan que tiene para sus
primeros 100 días de gobierno que va a
estar enfocado en la crisis de la
pandemia y la parte de económica del
país así como otros temas sociales como
en ustedes entonces a la bancada de los
demócratas y al presidente yo vayan para
arrancar este inicio de gobierno
teniendo este juicio político ahí
respirando en el cuello maikel
bueno yo tengo la impresión que que el
equipo del baile está realmente ha
empezado muy bien os haya nombrado un
equipo gabinete bien competente con
mucha experiencia y conocimiento
cientistas y todos los demás entonces yo
creo que está listo estar preparando y
por eso no quiere algo que demora o
desvía su gran enfoque el problema es
que con el senado a pesar de que los
demócratas tienen el control es 50 y 50
y creo que muchos de los propuestas más
ambiciosas que tal vez quiere el partido
demócrata y quiere presentar bailén
no va a ser posible vas a tener que
negociar mucho y va a terminar con
propuestas más moderadas más más débiles
que muchos sectores de partidos
demócratas quisieran tener pero esa es
la política tiene que haber una
negociación entre moderados demócratas y
moderadas republicanos y yo creo que
esto lo que vamos a ver
yo tengo muchas esperanzas que si el
presente baile puede aprovechar ese
momento para arrancar muy bien en sus
primeros 100 días y césar su opinión al
respecto
bueno yo creo que aquí juega la
inteligencia de los legisladores de los
nuevos legisladores también recordemos
que en la cámara los demócratas
perdieron varias sillas y en el senado
como lo mencionaba michael aunque
ganaron dos sillas los demócratas queda
a 50 50 y el voto que parte de eso es la
vicepresidente que meier
y yo creo que lo importante es ver si
verdaderamente el tema de las
instituciones presidente va a retrasar
la agenda del presidente by de hoy nada
más anunció su nuevo plan
a atacar el tema de coronavirus incluye
1.9 trillones de dólares y eso requiere
una aprobación en la cámara alta y baja
y de eso requiere obviamente
negociaciones tratos conversaciones es
ver cómo arregla de eso y creo que si se
enfocan solamente en el tema de la
institución va a retrasar este proyecto
de ley que es prioridad para el
presidente baile yo lo de aquí lo más
importante es ver qué pesa más en la
balanza obviamente ya se ha hecho y
altera el presidente en la cámara con el
tema de la decisión del presidente pero
ver si dedicar todo el esfuerzo político
de estos primeros 100 días en ese tema
única y exclusivamente beneficio el
pueblo americano en total o simplemente
termina siendo percibido por la gente
con una postura política yo creo que lo
más importante es el tema de coronavirus
el tema de cómo reabrir la economía
rápidamente
y en eso pues queda la inteligencia de
los legisladores vamos a ver cómo decir
sin duda alguna el presidente electo joe
biden tendrá un peculiar inicio de
gobierno y también muy peculiar es ese
momento que está viviendo estados unidos
la militarización de las ciudades sobre
todo de washington la capital del país
ustedes dos como ciudadanos o residentes
allí en eeuu como están viviendo esta
presencia militar en las calles
custodiando los capitolios custodiando
los edificios gubernamentales algo quien
a lo que los estadounidenses no están
acostumbrados
michaels washington y dos cuadras de
aquí donde digo está la guardia nacional
hay tropas que están parando todos los
carros están cerrando todas las calles y
no es muy cercano al capitolio o sea es
otro sector de bolívar dónde de la
ciudad pero dos cuadras a la guardia
nacional por todos parte eso es
obviamente muy descontó desconcertante
no hay repito no hay precedentes para
esto
en este país por lo menos en los últimos
el siglo 21 del siglo 20 digamos yo creo
que es algo histórico la gente está con
mucha ansiedad de lo que podría pasar
hay informes de inteligencia bien
preocupantes
entonces el todo creo los ciudades por
lo menos de este pack de esta ciudad
están muy tensas en este momento
esperando que podemos pasar este día con
tranquilidad y sin ninguna violencia y
césar su perspectiva en miami donde haya
una gran comunidad hispana y en el sur
del estado de la florida yo creo que en
general porque recordemos que en todas
las capitales y obviamente se ha puesto
más guardia lo importante es proteger a
nuestros líderes políticos también al
final del día ellos han sido electos
independientemente de si estamos en su
punto de vista político o no en este
momento representan sectores de nuestra
población y eso es importante
protegerlos ahora a ellos pero esto yo
creo que es
te muestra un resultado de la
polarización que en el país de las
pasiones de que lleva a gente a cometer
cosas terribles como la de la semana
pasada y cómo podemos llegar realmente a
bajarle un poquito al tono a la
discusión empezamos a escuchar y poder
llegar al diálogo sin tener que estar
aterrorizados de estar en desacuerdo con
algo entonces alguien va a salir a
manifestarse como fue la semana pasada o
en el verano pasado también cuando
habían estos desórdenes en el webcast de
eeuu pues ya veremos cómo se desarrolla
esta historia el 20 de enero cuando el
presidente de donald trump entregue el
poder al presidente electo joe biden a
césar grajales en miami y michael
schifter en la ciudad de washington
gracias por habernos acompañado en el
debate de france 24 de ustedes también
gracias por su sintonía pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios en las redes
sociales siga con nosotros sigan
france24
[Música]